great to have Cris Collinsworth how are
you Chris Goodrich what's happening man
what do you think of last night it was
just fun I guess I love it when
footballs Bondi and I've got to say this
whole year has been pretty fun they
we've seen the scoring go through the
roof and never more obvious than what it
was last year I think the league has
done a great job this year of not over
reacting to some of the the social
debates that happened in the United
States especially during this political
season and political time and we really
focused on the game of football in a way
that I don't think happened in a number
of years and so I for me I don't know if
everybody feels that way but I feel like
the game has really been focused on the
field this year and it's just been fun
it's been high-scoring it's great
personalities great young quarterbacks
been great so what do you take out of it
from last night what can be portable for
us to focus on from Thanksgiving here on
out from these two teams that are at the
tops of their conferences I mean it
looks like those big three are still the
big three right I think you have to
throw the Saints in there as well and
then there's a couple of Givens I mean
we know what's what's still to come
right I mean the Patriots are still
gonna make their run and they look bad
but against Tennessee and they're you
know people are calling me wanting to
say is this really the real end cuz we
don't want to come to Tom Brady I'm like
you know I've been asked that question
for the last six years every time they
have a bad game so now you know unless I
really see it Pittsburgh I think still
obviously capable of making a run a
Houston is kind of an
intimidating-looking team to me right
now as far as a team that could be
somewhere in the surprise but I also
think that we may see defense rear its
ugly head here before well I mean don't
you feel that like Chicago last night
I'm watching Dallas has a hell of a
defense
Minnesota's defense can kick it into
gear you know you can you can kind of
just go Houston should be able to do it
Tennessee so somewhere along the line
you know we're gonna get the the waking
dead and the zombies are gonna you know
come to life and and all that kind of
stuff before we're all said and Cris
Collinsworth here in the Honda inside a
report and it's interesting you
mentioned the Bears obviously you and Al
saw them in Chicago with a huge win over
the Vikings on Sunday Night Football to
me while we're having this conversation
about you say defense rearing its its
head obviously you've got you've got
Khalil Mack and you know the rest of
that defense to me though the offense
seeing the way that that is being built
there when we see what we saw last night
and you know it's a copycat league it
seems to me that that's the style that's
gonna be sustainable for the next ten
years as opposed to what we saw over the
last ten years is team speed guys spread
out all over the lot a young coach
dialing it up for a young quarterback
who's on his first contract so you can
pay the Khalil max to rush the passer
I'm wondering what you think Chris I
think there's a couple other things too
one you can't hit anybody anymore you
know which I see quarterbacks
that probably wouldn't by nature be
brave that are a lot braver standing in
the pocket anymore a little braver
running the football than what they've
been I've seen wide receivers who I
don't think would have been going over
the middle and tight ends going over the
middle back in the day when you could
hit them right underneath the chin and
see their helmet go flying off and you
know getting a set as new set of
stitches about every other game the way
it was at one time in the National
Football League so they're throwing a
lot of those sort of middle read jump
ball kind of things because yeah you can
hit me in the back I said don't bother
me yeah you know I've got I've got a
whole set of rib cage back there that's
that's not gonna hurt too badly and so I
think that plays that back in the day we
would have gone back to the quarterback
and gone you throw that again I'm gonna
beat your ass and I don't think that
it's that way anymore I think guys are
getting hit but not in the intimidating
fashion that takes away some of those
crossing routes and some of those slants
and some of those posts and middle reads
and all those crazy kind of things so
it's a little different game it's a
little more offense and and this running
quarterback thing is real I mean you
know when that that the outside
linebackers defensive ends and this
league now can't go flying down on those
inside and outside zone plays away from
them you have to play the bootlegs with
these kids with the way that they can
run and and it's it's more like
fast-break basketball it's kind of fun
to watch you know I'm enjoying it it is
fun it is fun Chris especially since
again like I like I've we've just been
talking about here in Los Angeles he got
the youngest coach in the league in
McVeigh with you know Jared Goff who is
playing like a lion right now and looks
like Bambi right and then you've got
Sean Payton and Drew Brees have been
attached to the hip for a dozen years
but now playing exactly this type of
offense that we're looking like without
the running ability and then an old
school law guy like Andy Reid who is
just I guess taking it up a notch from
the West Coast offense with his young
quarterback that's our poll question
today is which offense would you if you
had to choose one would you put your
marker down on right now you know I it's
a great question and I I don't know you
know McVeigh is the is the young gun and
he's gonna have a long shelf life and
goodness only knows how good he's gonna
get because he's so good right now I
mean what he did turning that that
operation around and now with receivers
getting hurt and it just it doesn't seem
to matter you know I don't think their
protection was great last night and you
know golfers you know make a mistake or
two but they just keep on chugging along
with all that stuff but I think that the
end of the day I think you have a choice
to make you know I think Golf is is a
little bit of the do everything and with
McVeigh you definitely have mahomes who
is I think the most athletic of that
group that you just mentioned he's and I
put true Biscay a little bit in that
group as well although I don't think he
throws it as well
is mahomes does but there's something
lurking in the back of my mind about
Drew Brees we had a graphic up the other
day and it's I don't know why I should
have known this I vote on the MVP every
year but when I read that he had not won
the MVP crazy oh you got to be kidding
me
I mean here's the guy that's been over
5,000 yards what five times something
like that I think more than all the rest
of the history of quarterbacks combined
he's been over 5,000 yards he's a Super
Bowl winner and I think he's just kind
of yang when other people have gained
when it came to the MVP you know
somebody even had better years and maybe
mahomes is the one that knocks the
mallet or Gurley or whoever it may be
this year but there's something about
what's going on in New Orleans right now
and their ability to create offense with
those two running backs and Michael
Thomas obviously but and when you look
at the defenses involved and I think the
potential is there in New Orleans for
that to be maybe just a notch above
what's happening right now in LA Kansas
City but who knows it's I always say the
season doesn't even start till we get to
Thanksgiving so happy football to you I
know exactly and you know normally when
somebody gets a lifetime achievement
award for you know when they didn't
haven't won an Oscar yet or they do
finally win their Oscar there I guess
across streams here sports and pop
culture it's for a movie that might not
be their best ever but it was definitely
enough good enough for that year this
could be breezes best year ever though I
mean what he's doing is absurd and in
terms of the offense with Sean Payton
they've thrown Taysom Hill in this mix
too so it's it's not just the the Peyton
Bri
offensive previous years he's adding
what everybody else is doing with a
totally different quarterback it is
something else with chimera and and an
Engram and
I've never I mean again your football
life's coming up so you've you know what
it's like running routes you know what
it's like running routes as a champion
in championship seasons Cris
Collinsworth I mean what this kid
Michael Thomas is doing is absurd he
could be having the grass best wide
receiver year ever and I understand what
I'm talking about with other people -
yeah and and I think that's the concern
with them is you know can some of those
younger receivers you know have an
impact but as long as they don't lose
Ingram and camara you know I think that
that one-two combination is is really
something but I I'm with you I love what
they're doing with Taysom Hill miss
Joker can fly he can throw the football
you completed his bomb in the game we
did against against the Vikings but I
think that it forces you to practice
other stuff I mean I remember in my son
played for Notre Dame and they used to
go in and play Navy or army or whatever
and you know they'd be on a roll
stopping offenses and playing well then
all of a sudden here comes the triple
option and it's like alright no I need
you guys to forget everything you know
about playing defense because now we got
to do this right and so now you end up
in the same situation when when you're
playing the Saints or you're playing
mahomes or you're playing trip Biscay
you know that backside runs support just
can't be there because they have to
settle in and play the quarterback and
it makes and then if you add the RTOS on
it I've taught you know we talked to
every defensive coordinator every week
and they're now to the point where they
go we can't cover all this we just can't
you know if they get the reads alright
we cannot we literally cannot cover we
cannot cover the the inside or outside
zone moving to the right without any
support from our backside linebacker we
can't cover the possibility of the
quarterback holding on to it and running
the football and we certainly can't
cover the the wide receiver
running a slant behind our linebacker if
he steps up to play the quarterback or
the inside zone so if they really get
this offense right we can't cover it and
so they have to sort of hope that
they're gonna make a mistake somewhere
along the way and that through pressure
or blitzing or whatever that they force
them into some bad bad plays a little
bit like what the Rams did last night
amazing Cris Collinsworth a few more
minutes left here in the Honda inside a
report you've got Packers Vikings this
Sunday night Chris in the sense that
that I'm seeing out there on the
Twitterverse as well as just general
conversation is that Aaron Rodgers has
seen a Monday night game like this or
what the Saints looked like against the
Eagles and that offense is in the house
and he is like John Cusack holding up
the the the boom box begging for that
offense to come out of the house for him
what do you think he is going through
right now as you get set for a big
must-have for the Packers on Sunday
night on that offense yeah we're down to
that point of the year which it's funny
when you call games for a long period of
time you start to understand you know in
a way I'm happy I'm almost happier
excuse me to be calling the Packers and
the Vikings and then two of the team
sitting at the very top because all
right they're already in the playoffs
these guys are playing for their lives
on Sunday night I mean they really are
in particular the Green Bay Packers at
this point and but I do think there's a
little hope there I think this Aaron
Jones excuse me is a guy that could be a
real difference maker coming down the
track and and I don't think they've used
him well enough yet when they find a way
to flip him the ball either on a screen
or a check down or whatever the case may
be
he really he creates some real offense
so could he be there Alvin camara he
might be he might be they they haven't
developed him to that point yet but they
have Davante Adams who is fantastic of
course now it looks like they're gonna
lose Jimmy Graham for a little while but
this Robert Tonja and we had a 50-yarder
last night he can run
Marquess Valdez candling you know and
and equi name is st. Brown the - I hope
I never have to say on the same place
are sitting there and they're talented
and but I think if you said what could
be the difference on this football team
coming down the stretch and as much as
Aaron Rodgers wants to win every game by
himself and he should because he's the
best player or one of the best players
and all of football if they can
establish that running game a little bit
more and use Aaron Jones a little bit
more in the passing game I still think
this team has the ability to go on a run
yeah III the other day I said and I'll
repeat adhere to Aaron Jones looks like
Kareem hunt to me looks a little bit Tim
hunt like to me Chris yeah any any silky
- you know he's can weave in and out he
can get when he gets the ball in space
now it's not always this is a tough team
to run to football against all those
bears did a pretty good job against the
Vikings sure did but but I do think that
that finding ways to get Aaron Jones
incorporated in some short quick passing
game and running the ball is what they
need to do okay before I let you go
Chris your football life Friday 8:00
Eastern Time have you seen it yet were
you your news contain thought today
actually my wife is going to kill me
because I promised her I'd sit around
but I just I just couldn't wait anymore
and you know it was my god it's so it's
so honest and it's so brutal brutally
honest and a few occasions you kind of
cringe yeah like what made you like what
Chris give me a little hint little tease
for Friday no it takes you back to
losing Super Bowls and takes you back to
you know the people at Philadelphia are
so mad after my call a Super Bowl
question and those two touchdowns and
the officials called all that kind of
stuff so anyway it just kinda and then
they show your kids say a nice stuff
about you and you make you want to cry
and you know for and then you feel like
god they're doing a football life is
that how old am I now wait a minute now
I used to be the kid among the
announcers and now I'm like this older
veteran and
I didn't even play for the Dallas
Cowboys so all kinds of strange things
happening right now but it was it was
fun it was funny James whiner I'm saying
his last name right is so talented oh my
god he like he gets inside your soul and
and I always loved the football life
series and so it was an easy yes for me
when they they asked me to do it but it
does it it is not a superficial look at
what I do or what I have done it digs in
a little bit but I appreciate it as the
guy who's trying to make a living being
honest over the years and they were
honest about me well you now are awesome
man as you know Chris and I appreciate
the time have a great Thanksgiving I
know that the studio crews doing the
Thursday night NBC Thanksgiving night
game and we'll see you on on the tube on
Friday night on the NFL Network with
your football life and then Sunday night
with Packers and Vikings I'll be settled
in all right back at you that's Cris
Collinsworth that Collinsworth PFF the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience